hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
you may remember me from videos about
other viral math problems
right now the internet is going crazy
over another problem so it's time for
the order of operations to save the day
what is eight divided by two parentheses
two plus two equal to
we'll calculate this using the order of
operations commonly remembered by pemdas
or bodmus
we'll start with the parentheses
two plus two is equal to four
we then have a division and a
multiplication
when you have operators of the same
precedence you work from left to right
so we take 8 divided by 2 first
this evaluates to be 4 and then we
complete the multiplication of 4 by 4
and we get 16.
this is without a doubt the correct
answer according to the modern
interpretation of the order of
operations
but let's do a little thought experiment
let's travel back in time a hundred
years
i actually found an academic paper
discussing this very ambiguity in 1917.
how would they solve this problem
they also would start with the
parentheses and 2 plus 2 would be equal
to 4.
but then they would interpret this
expression a little bit differently
at that time mathematical type setting
was limited so if you had something like
x divided by 2y you would understand
it's x over the quantity 2y
so for this expression we would take 8
divided by 2 multiplied by 4.
that's because it would be hard to write
this expression in the limited type
setting of the time
so they would complete this as two
multiplied by four
this will be equal to eight and then we
have eight over eight which is equal to
one
this is not the correct answer
today so let me address some of the
issues about this problem
some people will say they learned it a
different way
please let us know a textbook or printed
reference because we always want to
learn how math was taught over the years
what about the distributive property
it really doesn't have anything to do
with the correct answer eight divided by
two parentheses two plus two is
definitely equal to eight divided by two
multiplied by four
the question is whether to do eight
divided by two first or two multiplied
by four
what about implied multiplication
many calculators will treat it like
regular multiplication as i'll show
later in the video
is the question even well defined
it's as well defined as asking what is
the sum of angles in a triangle
almost everyone is going to answer 180
degrees but that's only according to the
assumptions of plane geometry or
euclidean geometry
similarly eight divided by two
parentheses two plus two is equal to
sixteen according to the modern
interpretation of the order of
operations just as there are
non-euclidean geometries there can be
non-modern ways or other ways of
interpreting this but the modern
interpretation is 16.
to elaborate on this point
some people would say the expression is
ambiguously written so there is no
correct answer it is analogous to a
poorly written sentence
consider i saw the man with binoculars
did you use binoculars to see the man
or did you see a man who had binoculars
in his possession
there's a point to be made here just as
we should write precise sentences we
should write precise mathematical
expressions
but in practice we have to resolve
ambiguity just as courts interpret and
make rulings on ambiguous laws
calculators parse and evaluate seemingly
ambiguous expressions
so how would they parse this expression
what happens when you actually put this
into a calculator
the calculator will use its own program
order of operations and one way to
visualize this is a binary expression
tree
so let's take this expression and we
need to parse it into just binary
expressions where we take two things at
a time
most calculators will do this
one subtree will be eight divided by two
another subtree will be two plus two
and then finally we multiply these two
results and we get the answer of
sixteen but there is another way you
could interpret this expression if you
put a parenthesis right here
this binary expression tree will look
very different
at the very bottom we have two plus two
we then take two multiplied by this
result and then we take 8 divided by
this result
this would give the answer of 1 but
that's not how most calculators will do
it
just to give you an example let's input
this expression into google
how does it parse this expression
well it gives the answer of 16 and if
you look very closely it parses it
exactly like the binary expression tree
on the left
this is how most calculators and
programming languages will interpret
this expression
i love that the internet is so
passionate about these problems it will
spur interest in mathematics and
definitely lead to mathematical
discoveries
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you